so it should be clear how important
genetic analysis is
for reconstructing evolutionary trees
yet it has not always been so clear
when zucker candle and pauling wrote
half a century ago
that hemoglobin offered a good basis for
comparing humans to gorillas
prominent biologist gaylord simpson shot
them down in impressive fashion
saying that their proposal was nonsense
now today
simpson lies on the wrong side of
history but at the time
perhaps zucker candle and pauling were
the radicals
since that time genetic analysis has
been applied to answer a
huge number of biological questions
related to evolutionary tree
reconstruction
for example until the 1980s it was
unclear whether the giant panda
should be classified as a bear or as a
marsupial
the giant panda looks like a bear in
some ways
but it's also similar to raccoons in
other ways
the panda doesn't hibernate in the
winter and its male genitalia
are tiny and backward pointing
i'm going to let you insert your own
joke on that one
in 1938 edwin colbert wrote
so the quest has stood for many years
with the bear proponents and the raccoon
adherents
and the middle of the road group
advancing their several arguments with
the clearest of logic
while in the meantime the giant panda
lives serenely in the mountains of
sichuan
with never a thought about the
zoological controversies he is causing
by just being himself now whereas
using anatomical or behavioral
characters led to endless debate in this
subject
steve o'brien used genetic data in 1985
to demonstrate that the giant panda
should in fact be considered a bear
a conclusion that has lasted to this day
we can also turn genetic analysis inward
onto ourselves
and construct an evolutionary tree for
human populations
when we look at this tree we see a very
clear division into africans
shown in red and non-africans shown in
other colors
where each color represents a different
continent
but we also see that the most recent
common ancestor
of all non-africans is at a much more
recent point
than the most recent common ancestor of
all africans
which is at the root of the tree in 1987
rebecca cann mark stoneking and alan
wilson deduced from this information
that because the origin of modern humans
predates the origin of all non-africans
all non-africans must have originated
somewhere in africa
this became known as the out of africa
hypothesis
and although it is still the subject of
some debate it has become widely
accepted today
as more genotyping data has been
obtained researchers have been able to
infer human migrations
around the world from evolutionary trees
yet this is not to say that genetic data
immediately is able to answer
all of our questions one problem arises
when different genetic data sets yield
differing phylogenys
for example using the dopamine d4
receptor gene
suggested that chimpanzees were closer
to gorillas than they were to humans
on the other hand if we used the beta
globin gene
that suggested that chimpanzees were
closer to humans than they were to
gorillas
not until 1996 did enough genetic data
become available
to conclude that the phylogeny on the
right is most likely the correct one
even at the beginning of this century
many biologists
believed that humans are more closely
related to dogs
than humans are related to mice this
seems reasonable since we seem to be
more similar to dogs than mice at first
glance
but recent research has shown otherwise
as indicated by this phylogeny
finally evolutionary trees constructed
from genetic analysis have even been
used as evidence
in criminal trials a landmark instance
of this occurred in 1998
when a doctor in louisiana went on trial
for the attempted murder of his
estranged mistress
she claimed that he had injected her
with an hiv tainted syringe
after the police chief collected hiv
samples from around the area
researchers constructed an evolutionary
tree for these samples
and what they found was that the hiv
samples from the victim
shown here in blue were similar to
samples taken from one of the doctors
patients
shown in red this evidence supports
conviction
which was the eventual verdict but this
evolutionary tree taken by itself
is far from conclusive which is what
brings us to the challenge problem for
this chapter
the evolutionary tree that we
constructed on the previous slide
was constructed based on an alignment of
just one hiv protein
what happens when you construct
alignments for other hiv proteins
do they all support conviction or do
some of these other proteins paint a
murkier picture
so i will let you go and work on
implementing the algorithms for
evolutionary tree construction that we
have encountered in this chapter
i want to say thank you for joining me
on this journey
i can only hope that this chapter has
been as enjoyable for you as it has been
for me